بعد لندن وباريس يصل الرئيس الاوكراني
فولدمير زيلنسكي بصحبه نظيره الفرنسي الى
بروكسيل لحضور قمه خاصه للاتحاد الاوروبي
حول الحرب في اوكرانيا
امام اعضاء البرلمان الاوروبي الذين
استقبلوه بحراره يحاول للمره الاولى منذ
بدء الحرب اقناع الغرب وجها لوجه بتعزيز
دفاعاتك وبتسريع محادثات عضويه بلاده في
الاتحاد
اتواجد امامكم اليوم للدفاع عن مدخل
اوروبا الاوكرانيون جميعا بمختلف اعمارهم
وقناعاتهم الدينيه وطبقاتهم الاجتماعيه
يتشاركون هذا الهدف كل شخص منا لديه قصه
خاصه لكننا نتشارك جميعا تاريخ المشتركا
وهو تاريخ اوروبا نحن اوروبيون يتعرض
اسلوب حياه الاوكراني والاوروبي للخطر لو
سقطت اوكرانيا سيسقط اسلوب حياتكم اسلوب
حياه سبع وعشرين دوله في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولا يمكننا ان نسمح بذلك
مطالب وزلنسكي لم تتغير طائرات مقاتله
حديثه وصواريخ بعيده المدى اسلحه ما تزال
الدول الغربيه تتردد بشان امداد كيافتها
يجب ان نعطي الاولويه لعمليات التسليم
المفيده لكاف على المدى القصير بدلا من
الحديث عن التزامات ستصل على المدى البعيد
كذلك لم يدلي باي تصريحات متعلقه
بالمقاتلات التي يطلبها زيلينسكي واكتفى
بالقول ان بلاده من بين اكبر الداعمين
الاوروبيين لاوكرانيا